bienvenue dans le studio diagonale tv
pour une nouvelle émission aujourd'hui
un peu spéciale aux nationaux 2015
cinquantaine 2004 ce championnat de
france puisque je reçois jean olivier
lecomte
bonjour jean olivier bonjour stéphane
alors les auditeurs te connaissent des
spectateurs qui ne te connaissent pas
forcément
mais tu es maître fide et oui tout à
fait une dizaine d'années 2300 à peu
près et vous alors voilà ça ça évolue
pub pas trop étant dès que je joue pas
énormément donc là c'est pas ton
activité plastiquement long moment et
mais tu es déjà donc un joueur qu'il
écume un petit peu les tournois
notamment sur paris tours rapides j'ai
beaucoup joué étant très jeune j'avais
une vingtaine d'années et l'avant
dernier tournoi deux parties nombre
montera après deux ans en fait et tu es
marié avec une star ni nefic
une star oui un bien grand mot rime à
rien le groupe sétois devait donc le
marc de l'ariège qui a joué la nationale
oui elle joue nationale en ce moment et
qui a été championne de france était
championne de france une fois en 2001 à
marseille et c'était une bonne année
l'année 2001 puisque dans la foulée avec
maryse bailly queiroz a t elle l'avait
emporté en espagne
championnats d'europe par équipes avec
la france bon mais c'était une année un
peu spéciale de milan est ce que nous
semble que la russie n'avait pas
participé à chanter ça aide
ça avait des mais le résultat avait été
exceptionnel avec maryse bague qui était
très jeune à l'époque qui avait vraiment
tout c'est l'équipe avec un résultat
exceptionnel pour marie et puis qui
maria et rosa qui suivait ça a joué sur
deux équipiers elle avait également fait
une excellente performance et du coup
mais l'ont emporté à ce jour le seul
titre d'une équipe de nationale 1
française en europe en oeuvre la draille
en championnat devant tous même aux
olympiades puisque je crois que on
n'arrête pas de rien il y en a à la
pelle vivre alors donc forcément vous
entraîner à tous les deux il ya quand
même il ya une émulation oui tout à fait
et puis marianne joue un petit peu plus
que moi donc je travaille ils ont pour
elles quand j'ai quand j'ai du temps
libre et jeu j'essaye de regarder des
télés telle variante du montrer quelles
étaient les positions intéressantes pour
qu'elle fasse un peu de calcul mais
disons que maria elle a eu également un
peu moins que qu'auparavant puisque elle
se consacre principalement à
l'enseignement des échecs auprès des
enfants
là où on habite on est dans le val de
marne à saint mandé donc il ya un grand
club
tout pour les enfants là bas et ça
marche bien
et beaucoup d'enfants et une centaine
d'enfants elle enseigne également dans
les écoles donc voilà elle consacre
beaucoup de temps à ça donc du coup bah
enfin en tant que joueuse d'échecs elle
est un peu moins présente un rapport
présente il faut tempérer parce que la
levée nationale quand même de très bonne
qualité on est dans les premières et lui
souhaite bien sûr le meilleur pour la
suite
alors tu n'es pas dans cette émission
pour parler de mariage même si c'est
normal qu'on en parle un peu puisque
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important
bien entendu mais tu es venu parce que
tu tiens un blog qui traite d'un lieu
français meetic
tu t'es dit est dédié à ce sujet là et
ça c'est tout à fait remarquable pour
l'histoire du jeu puisque tu traite donc
de tutu mais un jour un blocus qui parle
le café donc de la régence moutons à
parler de cette émission
à l'occasion de la sortie de son livre
alors je crois que même que le tome 2 on
va sortir en septembre
voilà je fais en sorte pour que pour
qu'il soit prêt en septembre en fait et
le tort il est la sortie voilà donc ces
cafés envers les cafés de la régence
voilà le bouquin et puis alors regarder
un c'est pas un petit bouquin c'est
quand même une somme voilà le café sur
le café de la régence par donc je
olivier lecomte donc beaucoup de travail
c'est de combien d'années que tu t'es
mis là dessus alors je suis pas arrivé
tout de suite sur le sujet en me disant
maintien je vais écrire un livre qui
fait 600 pages pas du tout donc j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser un peu à ce lieu
est ce que moi je m'intéresse à
l'histoire et puis même à l'histoire des
échecs
forcément quand on est un joueur
d'échecs on s'intéresse quand même un
petit peu aux aspects culturels du jeu
donc j'ai vu qu'il y avait énormément de
choses sur ali king capable donc les
champions du monde dans les années 60
mais globalement sur le 19e siècle ou
même avant les quasiment aucun matériel
ou c'est difficile de trouver quelque
chose donc progressivement je me suis
intéressé à ça puis j'ai découvert non
ce lieu le café de la régence qui a été
un lieu emblématique pour le jeu
d'échecs pendant pendant un peu plus de
deux siècles et j'ai découvert cet appât
et je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
absolument rien sur le sujet donc ça
c'était au début des années 2000 donc un
petit peu en dilettante je me suis
intéressé et puis le temps est passé et
où en 2010 je crois qu'il ya des zones
un piia dans russie sentiment de 6 qui
est un ami et la cérémonie d'ouverture
était c'est un ballet avec comme décor
le café de la région c'est un spectacle
sur ce thème
donc je me suis dit tiens les russes ça
les intéresse c'est quand même étonnant
ça les a marqués voilà ça les marques
ça les a marqués salle et marque encore
et en fouillant un petit peu je me suis
rendu compte que
on pouvait trouver gratuitement sur
internet à un cahier qui fait presque
deux cents pages mis à disposition sur
le site internet du club
alors le creps qu'est-ce que ça c'est le
cercle de donner moi dans le sac royal
d'échec de broxeele l'instant et donc il
ya un un joueur n'a pas qui a écrit un
fascicule assez complet sur le café de
la région sont mais qui traite
principalement moi je trouve qu'ils
aient trait principal la partie 1850
1940 à peu près mais il manquait des
éléments encore à qui allait une
nouvelle fois quelque chose qui est qui
me piquer au vif ses voilà les russes
qui intéresse des belges s'y intéresse
on trouve aussi des informations sur des
sites allemands qui parle du café latte
et pyrénées sur le site de la fff
on n'en parle pas je n'en sais pas ce
que c'est sûr sur des sites français
nulle part j'ai trouvé des informations
et pourtant c'est intéresse vraiment il
ya des gens qui que ça touche sur
l'histoire du jeu on voit que yahia tuez
pas le seul commencé à faire de
l'histoire du jeu ont suivi l'entrée
direction alors évidemment il ya eu on a
eu françois lui donner on a eu une
nicolas giffard si tu as fait qu'on
écrit des recueils et actuellement il ya
un site qui s'appelle héritage france et
la cause est excellent
dominique timonier qui fait un historien
je crois d'ailleurs je ne le connais pas
en fait j'ai changé un petit peu avec
lui par email mais je ne le connais pas
personnellement et le travail qu'il
fournit sur sur les échecs en france
alors c'est principalement son site sur
le xxème siècle en wade et moi je trouve
ça excellent j'y vais régulièrement où
il le met à jour où à peu près tous les
tous les six mois à venir et il apporte
du matériel à chaque fois qu'ils étaient
totalement nouveau alors on va parcourir
un peu ce blog d'abord avant de parler
du livre
alors je vous rassure tout de suite on
aura aussi une partie d'échecs commenté
dans l'émission ça sera pas qu'eux mais
on va aussi passer du temps sur des
images un petit peu des articles de café
sont vivants juste si tu me permets moi
il y avait aussi il ya aussi quelque
chose qui est important à dire je pense
au sujet du café de l'argence quand on
regarde une activité que ce soit un
sport une religion
n'importe quelle activité il existe
toujours un lieu emblématique pour les
religions bas pour les musulmans c'est
la mecque avec la cabab
je sais pas pour les footballeurs ça
peut être le stade du nou camp
il ya plein de lieux comme ça qu'ils
sont vraiment emblématique pour pour le
sport c'est facile de trouver pour les
échecs on reste un petit peu en suspens
audi tient effectivement il n'y a pas ce
lieu et y avis qui restait qu'un aliment
avec le match hier ce pas ce qui bien
sûr mais
mais c'est pas aussi marqué ces voix là
là on avait en france à paris un lieu où
sont passés tous les champions du monde
et avant les champions de monde tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde se faisait un
devoir de passer là quand ils venaient à
persister une étape obligatoire on va le
voir d'ailleurs puisqu'on verra une
surprise un moment donné alors donc
parcours un petit peu là on voit il ya
des belles images alors on utilise à
récupérer ces images ici la sic alors
c'est que ça par exemple alors cette
image alors là j'ai gelé commenté donc
c'est une représentation alors c'est une
vue d'artiste
c'est une représentation du café de la
régence en 1770 1700 sony mais il est là
c'est la rue n'est pas bonne route alors
dès lors le café de la régence il n'a
pas été à un seul endroit et il ya
apparu place du palais royal
donc à la fin du xviiie siècle en france
en fait et suprin sip allemand à paris
il ya une nouvelle boisson qui arrive
qui s'appelle le café donc il ya
quelques fois qu'ils sont organisées
notamment une fois dans le quartier
saint-germain où il ya des italiens
principalement qui apportent des cette
nouvelle boisson qui vient du yémen qui
qui passe par par la turquie qui arrive
en europe occidentale
ce que jusqu'à présent les lieux où les
gens à les voir et se distraire c'était
des tadornes un début un peu sombre les
boissons s'est principalement du vin de
la bière
et puis c'est pas forcément des lieux
très accueillants et donc avec ces
nouvelles boissons un peu plus raffiné
dont quelques a fait il ya d'autres
boissons qui viennent d'italie aussi
avec gêne et et venise qui ont des
échanges commerciaux avec la turquie
dont il ya des nouvelles boissons qui
arrive en europe et n'y en a qui ont une
bonne idée de créer des lieux un peu
plus accueillant un peu plus clinquant
avec des beaucoup de fenêtres beaucoup
de de glace en fait pour ok beaucoup de
lumière dans ces lieux et donc ça attire
une couche sociale différente que les
tavernes sacré des nouveaux lieux de
rencontre et donc en cette fin du xviie
siècle sur la place du palais royal
pour ceux qui connaissent un petit peu
paris
la place du palais royal c'est une belle
place à ces grandes parcelles 17e siècle
c'est plutôt 1600 voilà vers 1680 1680
les premières traces que j'ai trouvé
qu'ils mentionnent un café sur la place
sa date de 7 780 parce qu'il faut quand
même bien situer qui est assez difficile
de trouver des traces d'un commerce
essayez de d'imaginer comment trouver
des traces d'un commerce des xviième
siècle c'est pas quelque chose qui
présentent un intérêt historique
flagrant et donc trouver une référence
un lieu pareil alors pourquoi le
pourquoi le nom café de la régence de
nous expliquer contexte historique tout
à fait un oncle déjà il commencera par
s'appeler le café la région c'est le
café de la place du palais royal
et il se passe un événement en 1715 de
mémoire me sens en septembre donc loup
le 14
des cèdres et le son successeur donc le
futur losc y en a que quelques années je
sais plus exactement entre qu'il a 5 ans
quelque chose comme ça donc il ya un
régent qui est qui est nommé pour notre
beau wehrling qui est qui elle fit un
fils d'orléans de mémoire et donc fi
d'orner en main il est chargé de de la
régence en attendant que louis 15
atteignent l'âge de la majorité alors la
majorité à l'époque il me semble c'est
treize ans et pas moi la majorité pour
que louis 15 fils gouverne majorité
royal la majorité royal voilà donc le
le régent il installe son gouvernement
au palais royal et donc du coup le
centre politique de la france devient le
palais royal avec la place qui se trouve
devant et probablement à l'occasion d'un
changement de propriétaire du lieu donc
le sait un certain le faire cette époque
donc ce lefebvre probablement lui on en
a pas de certitude mais moi j'ai pas
trouvé de documents qu'ils le trouvent
donc se le faire un décide de renommer
le café et de l'appeler donc le café de
la régence donc ça se passe en 1718 et
pourquoi on a cette certitude
est-ce que sur la devanture du café on
en parlera encore flou mais il ya eu une
pancarte jusqu'au début du 20e siècle où
il y avait écrit le café la régence
maison fondée 1718
voilà 1718 mais en fait il existait
avant sous un autre nom
il existe avant sous un autre nom alors
après il ya un autre mystère c'est de
savoir quand les joueurs d'échecs sont
arrivés dans ce café 1
voila voila ca c voilà par exemple sur
cette image on revient ça on nous voit
sur la bouche doit me voile la régence
alors c'est white aux cafés fondée en
1718 voilà donc c'était totalement voilà
cette photo où on la trouve à plusieurs
endroits et notamment
dans le livre de jacques il re jacques
il reste à un historien qui a fait un
livre grandiose sur l'histoire de paris
n'est la première édition date des
années 60 et on trouve sur son article
sur la rue saint-honoré au moment où il
parle en quelques lignes café lorient
sont trouve cette photo magnifique ce
qu'il est les documents visuels sur
lequel fait la région sont extrêmement
alors justement le cas justement c'est
qu'elle adresse aujourd'hui si on veut
aller voir le lieu où c'était à l'heure
où exactement
voilà ce que donc initialement le comme
j'ai dit le café la réussite et sur la
place du palais royal
il ya eu des travaux - qui sur sous
napoléon iii ont que napoléon iii à
lancer les grands travaux les fameux
travaux d'haussmann mais une des
premières choses qu'il a voulu réaliser
napoléon iii c'est un projet qui
existait bien auparavant c'était le
percement de la rue de rivoli
alors le
si vous si vous allez au musée du louvre
actuellement vous avez quelque chose
d'assez compact et avec des des façades
qui court tout le long de la rue de
rivoli puis une grande ouverture vers le
jardin des tuileries
mais à l'époque la configuration n'était
pas du tout comme ça savoir sur la place
du palais royal
il y avait il y avait des rues qui
partait de la place du palais royal et
qui allaient à l'intérieur de ce qu'on
appellerait le louvre et donc c'était un
quartier qui était pas très bien
fréquenté non plus et un appeau les
endroits veut assainir un petit peu tout
ça donc ils rénovent complètement la
place du palais royal en l'agrandissant
et du coup en 1854 le café l'argent ces
expulsés le propriétaire non doit aller
ailleurs et c'est un propriétaire qui
s'appelle claude viel qui décide de
continuer la tradition du jeu d'échecs
et de ne pas abandonner ce lieu et il
fait reconstruire un petit peu plus loin
donc dans la rue saint-honoré hier faire
construire un autre café de la région
sont d'accord est ce cette autre café de
la régence est ouvert et inaugurée en
août 1855 garde lors qu'on est très loin
après la régence de le tout à fait on en
est très loin mais bon deux
de café géographiquement il se trouve à
200 mètres de l'ancien café non qui se
retrouvent
rue saint-honoré où 161 actuellement
donc je vais revenir dessus donc il est
inauguré en août 1855 à l'occasion de la
visite du nord et l'angleterre jusque là
qu axel et alors alors on a peut-être
poursuivre le blog met alors à noter sur
cette page ici forcément on obligé aussi
on est passé de 1680 à 1850 là tu me
ravit évidemment là a marseille il faut
pas faire comme ça il faut faire comme
ceux ci servira mieux voilà évidemment
il ya un grand monsieur qui a qui a joué
au père fait de l'argent voilà un des
ben disons 'peut-être le le seul qui
vient spontanément à l'esprit des
joueurs d'échecs parce qu'ils allaient
c'est quand même un livre fondamental
pour pour le pour le jeu d'échecs ont
donc cessé philidor qui est qu'il y
avait une
double claque casquette si on veut dire
donc c'est il était compositeur de
musique c'est pratiquement nuit qui a
créé l'opéra comique donc lancer des
opérettes
on peut voir ça comme ça et donc d'un
philidor si vous allez dans le quartier
de l'opéra garnier
alors pas l'opéra bastille l'opéra
garnier et si vous faites le tour du
bâtiment vous apercevrez qu'il ya pas
mal de bustes de grands compositeurs et
notamment celui de philidor et si on
remarque alors j'espère si c'est fait
exprès on est en dessous de son bus et
un écusson avec un échiquier dessus je
pense pas que ce soit le fait du hasard
mais non bien sûr que non
et là il ya sa place ici a noté qu'il a
aussi mourut à pas rien il ya une rue
fille dans tout à fait dans le 20e
arrondissement
alors moi j'avais fait une photo de la
plaque de rue ont gelé mis sur wikipédia
ali est maintenant d'accord
donc je pense que ça serait bien que tu
mettes sur cette photo ce qu'il a fait
oui on l'a
la trouve partout mais voilà il fallait
les particulièrement plu oublie que
celles qui seront alignés je crois
d'accord donc je pense qu'elle
mériterait d'être des êtres d'y être
mise alors à noter un bien alors souci
d'en parler un peu près rap forme c'est
bon voilà comme finis d'or était un
grand joueur du café la région et tu
parlais de son manuel
je vous rappelle que j'ai réédité l'an
dernier une réédition complète du manuel
du fameux manuel de feel it or voilà que
vous pouvez trouver en ligne ou séchées
les très bons livière les très bons
libraires il y en a quelques-uns voilà
qui nous le propose voilà une réédition
avec bien entendu toutes les parties en
format moderne c'est-à-dire notation
algébrique et échiquier ce qui n'est pas
évident parce que c'était écrit à
l'époque pour noter un coup il fallait
plusieurs phrases
oui bah il à la notation des échecs
c'est un problème récurrent a eu plein
de plein de façons noter les parties et
un creusement actuellement la notation
algébrique fait la plus simple et c'est
celle qui a point
alors on va pas de prix poursuit sur ton
blog mais pour voir aussi d'autres
d'autres schémas je change de page on va
ici alors le jeu des sept erreurs tu
nous fais un article ici sur le jeu des
sept erreurs qu'est ce que c'est
alors en fait je sais que c'est rick
alors le jeu des sept erreurs pourquoi
est ce que j'ai quand j'ai commencé à
mettre à jour le blog après j'ai été
voir un petit peu ce qui se faisait
sur le café l'argent notamment sur
wikipédia qui est qui qui pointent une
référence et en lisant l'article de
wikipédia sur le café de la région je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément d'erreurs est alors un jour
je me donnerai la peine
un boni à l'est et de modifier la wii
avec le travail que tu viens de faire la
sortie de ce livre je crois que tu es un
peu obligé de mettre au moins quelques
informations pour l'établir un petit peu
le vrai du faux
oui oui fois je le façon on compte sur
toi je vois très important alors en
avoir une autre une autre page toujours
sur ton blog ici voilà alors après la
simultanée alors voilà ça c'est une page
qui parle d'une simultanée de morphine
donc murphy le grand champion américain
voilà donc la question je me suis posée
après avoir écrit donc ce ce livre feu
c'est quel est l'événement qui a le plus
marqué le café de la régence et à mon
avis c'est la visite de paul murphy
là on peut re situer le contexte non
déjà c'est dans le nouveau café de la
régence au 161 rue saint-honoré
donc on est en 1858 donc mort il ya une
vingtaine d'années je moi j'ai vu son
âge exact en tête
il vient de remporter le premier congrès
des chèques américain oui
et forcément et
faut qu'ils viennent se mesurer en
europe avec les plus forts joueurs du
monde donc les plus forts joueurs du
monde à l'époque qui son bail à stone
town l'anglais voilà l'anglais qui
commence à être un petit peu âgé et il
ya également andersen donc le qui
siègeront des allemands il est prof de
marne et mattia breslau et il n'est pas
professionnel du jeu d'échecs
contrairement à stone town est d
andersen avait quand même marqué un
grand coup en remportant le premier
tournoi international de l'histoire à
londres en 1850 avec des produits
l'arrivée des pendules alors ainsi pas
très répandu c'est un petit peu après la
remise en jeu saint pandelon jeu il
jouait peut-être avec un sablier je ne
sais pas quand tu dis prometteur à cette
orientation je suis obligé de mettre en
uvre brise que le premier tournoi
international d'après les anciennes
sources
c'est quasi 160 plein d'espagne quelque
chose envoyez lopez avec pas ou le beau
leonardo dacourt thibault hésiter que 4
et c'était mais bon il y avait c'était
un cours commun c'était au cours du mois
c'était également dans le palais royal a
dit charles voilà du philippe ii à
philippe de la science de charles quint
voilà on est juste un peu après aux
jeunes experts nom pareil je vais faire
un peu susan en france ces démissions
littéraire ados gradins profitant même
temps je vous annonce la sortie
prochaine
la reddition complète procès jamais été
fait en france est en tout cas de façon
complète et pas depuis le 17e siècle du
traité de rui lopez voit la rue lopez
segura ont suivi vos émotions libéral
hier du jeu d'échecs
voilà avec une couverture de l'udc
poitiers
voilà une couverture qui fait un petit
peu manuels anciens donc ce bouquin il
fait 450 pages mais qui est moindre aux
voiliers que le livre que nous présente
jean olivier puisque le claf et la
région donc il y fait combien de plus
environ 600 pages 6 ans devra le premier
tome et c'est le premier tome
donc on n'est pas devant la même moi je
me suis fait plaisir en fait c'est alors
tu disais donc oui et donc je disais
juste c'est pas le premier tour
international il y avait ce fameux de
savoir c'est vraiment 475 il serait
qu'il n'a pas eu beaucoup entre les deux
sessions mais disons que ce tournoi de
1850 était était un petit peu unique
dans son nom dont il a lieu à l'occasion
de la première exposition universelle de
londres en 1850 et donc il attire des
joueurs de toute l'europe est le
représentant français qui ira là-bas
donc oui les français d'adoption c'est
un certain lionel qui est serré de ski
alors c'est un nom qui parle peut-être
pas beaucoup mais bon il a laissé quand
même son nom est mario du bambi du roi
et c'est également l'adversaire
d'andersen justement à londres en 1850
avec la fameuse partie mortels envers
celles qui essaient ritz qui il faut
seulement voir c'est tentant d'égorger
déchets c'est celle une partie que la
partie manqué la partie mortels donc
cette partie n'a pas été joué au tournoi
de londres 1150 bien qu'elle
elle a été jouée à londres en 1850 en
fait après le tournoi remporté par
andersen qui essaient ritz qui a fait un
match à jouer un match informel contre
anderson qu'il a d'ailleurs gagné est
une des parties de ce match c'est cette
partie mortels ou là par contre si ces
plantes et méchamment il s'est planté
méchamment et d'ailleurs dans sa revue
d'échec la régence puis ceux qui
essaient ritz qui écrivait dans il était
rédacteur en chef de la revue la régence
à l'époque ma il publie la partie en
s'arrêtant quelques coups avant la fin
c'est à dire il assume pas de cette fait
mater d'une telle façon dans la partie
dont kg mais les deux trois derniers
coups de la partie quand il publie pour
la première fois la partie mais tout en
félicitant son adversaire de cette
partie exceptionnelle d'accord alors
donc simultanée de morphine on vient là
simultanée de morphine donc mort fille
débarque en europe
1858 et commence par aller à londres
pour rencontrer cet automne et jouer un
match contre lui et le match n'a jamais
lieu à ce que stone town tergiverse et
moi je pense qu'il a peur de morphine
est en fait été dévoilé il est pétrifié
et donc du coup au bout d'un moment donc
murphy qui est accompagné de son
secrétaire frédéric edge qui a
d'ailleurs écrit tout un livre sur sur
son périple en europe est donc mort qui
décide d'un bien évidemment de se rendre
à paris au café de la régence pour pour
y rencontrer daniel arbitres alors
danielle arbid c'est également un des
plus forts joueurs d'europe c'est le
plus fort joueurs de l'époque du café de
l'argent si les allemands d'origine et
danielle arbid et comme staunton un
professionnel du jeu d'échecs
il a vraiment le jeu d'échecs dans la
poésie des leçons des chèques qui donne
au café de la régence il y des parties
handicap en trois ans venu pour revenir
sur le sujet qui remporte au café de la
région de voir ce qu'on va voir une
partie handicap totalement voilà et il a
également par un petit détail que j'ai
trouvé assez amusant il a surtout de ses
chemises il a des pièces d'échecs qui
sont brodés idée j'ai donc quand il
change de chemise mais il a des pièces
différentes sur sur saisie pour les
échecs et vie du jeu d'échecs enfin un
dernier gros coup voilà donc morphy
évidemment forcément intéressé pour
jouer contre lui donc il se rend au café
de la régence ils seront à paris au café
la régence et
les deux premières parties du match
contre arbitres
tourné au bénéfice dame saint vidian les
deux premières parties d'ailleurs il ya
un parallèle intéressant avec fisher au
fischer qu'on se passe qui perd les deux
premières parties contre spassky donc la
deuxième aussi par forfait et d'un
charisme gagne ses deux premières
parties et on peut dire c'est un peu le
temps d'adaptation de morphine ou vous à
son arrivée à paris quoi le voyage pour
aller de londres à paris c'est pas on
n'y a pas de tunnel sous la manche un
voyage assez assez éprouvant qui est qui
dure assez longtemps et donc après
morphine commence à emporter partie sur
partie contre arles x et arbitres se
fait porter pâles idée d'un coup qu'il a
acquis les malades un petit peu plus
haut donc c'est à la fois là exactement
les mener 5-2 devant oui quelque chose
comme ça donc bah du coup ma mort fille
décide déjà son son résultat contre avis
le fait connaître du tout paris marie à
l'époque sous napoléon iii et des avis
de d'avoir un héros et puis en plus il
ya une particularité à la mère de murphy
et française donc mort fille parle un
français impeccable et hilla ville vient
de louisiane aux etats unis aussi la
l'état le poufre ans exactement et donc
son sa connaissance du français ont fait
le saut ou en fait le chouchou et sa
popularité extrême et il ira même
jusqu'à jouer une partie en privé contre
napoléon iii donc on arrive
ah oui il joue une partie auprès des
voix la ccpo musée un fait qui n'est pas
très connu qui l'a invitée par la bien
être ce gène signé par napoléon iii dans
ses salons privés au palais des
tuileries il y jouera une partie mais ne
veut pas en faire de publicité mais la
preuve on n'a pas su voilà encore viens
juste de l'apprendre juste 221 ou 150
euros près alors on continue peut-être
juste entre nous est un peu j'ai fait un
peu plus que voilà essayant faire bref
donc pour passer le temps en attendant
que le match contre un vide se
reprennent donc il ya une simultanée à
l'aveuglé qui a organisé au café de la
régence donc mort fille joue conduite
des meilleurs joueurs parisiens donc
parmi ces joueurs parisiens il ya un
dénommé le kent pour l'anecdote c'est le
kent est un sculpteur très très célèbre
à l'époque c'est lui par exemple qui a
qui a créé la bonne mère de marseille
d'accord voilà il ya un apprend des
trucs
il ya également un certain jean pretty
qui va créer la revue la stratégie qui
est qui est un peu l'ancêtre d'europe
échec c'est une revue qui a existé
pendant presque 80 ans
voilà il ya pleins il ya des très forts
joueurs parisiens et morphine on joue l
aveugle et
semble qu'il a deux parties nulles et
emportent les autres sur des
combinaisons magnifique et donc il est
porté en triomphe quand elle sa sortie
du café de l'argent c'est une tellement
dense que les gardes armés du palais des
tuileries parce que c'est juste à côté
de là où logent l'empereur dont qui se
disent mince et encore une émeute
s'il faut il faut savoir que tout au
long du 19e siècle le palais royal la
place du palais royal est un lieu où où
se situe la plupart des manifestations
manifestation des émeutes ont eu trois
glorieuses 1830 les la révolution de
1848 avec la destruction du château
d'eau de la place du palais royal etc il
ya des combats très durs sur la place du
palais royal et il va aux calmants on y
va la mitraille et donc les gars n'ont
peur que ce soit de nouveau une émeute
qui démarre mais en fait non c'est mort
fille qui vient de remporter sa
simultanée et qui marque le public
parisien
voilà donc un grand moment du café la
région s'est simultanément fille tu nous
résumer alors un autre article
alors on va essayer d'accélérer parce
que sinon on n'aura jamais le temps de
regarder lille iii pourrait en parler
des heures chez soi il faut montrer
aussi des pages du livre donc il ya
quand même des petites les choses à voir
en essayant de faire un peuple libre est
maintenant donc ici on a un petit
article son origine épilogue en gros si
tu les dates de en gros de naissance et
de fin du café la réponse est oui mais
voilà ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
donc il ya deux aspects donc la création
du café large ans on a vu que c'est en
1718 peu après l'arrivée des joueurs
d'échecs contexte qui sont arrivés donc
là on n'a pas de certitudes
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas vu de certitudes
donc pendant l'ancien régime et même
après
les gouvernements ont toujours essayé de
lutter contre les jeux d'argent oui et
parce qu'on trouve de l'argent à
l'époque
voilà je partirai pas les jeux d'argent
je d'âge dans les jeux de hasard donc
c'était dans les tavernes les gens soyez
ouverte et il y avait des clubs des
clandestins et donc le jeu d'échecs qui
n'est pas un jeu de hasard commencent à
investir les cafés mais moi je veux si
tu ça peut-être vers 1720 25 dans ces
eaux là quoi alors le au début le café
de la régence n'avait pas l'exclusivité
du jeu d'échecs
il ya une alchimie qui s'est créée entre
les propriétaires les différents
propriétaires du café la régence qui se
sont succédé et le jeu d'échecs un étang
de cette alchimie elle tient tant que
les propriétaires ils sont sont
bienveillants vis-à-vis des joueurs
d'échecs tout va bien mais il suffit
qu'un propriétaire qui dit moi je veux
plus les joueurs des fesses qui sont là
il joue en 3 heures et il consomme une
tasse de café
c'est pas très rentable donc il y en a
il y en a certains tout au long de
l'histoire du café la région ce qui est
qu'ils n'ont pas voté on avait un peu
marre
et puis après avec ou 20e siècle là il
s'agit de faire du chiffre dans son
établissement donc c'est un petit peu ce
qui va provoquer la mort du café de la
régence donc vers quelle date a beaucoup
on peut dire alors ben ça c'est un des
petits secrets du deuxième tome en vente
la date exacte de la destruction du café
de la régence vous ment pas de la
destruction de la fin du café de la
régence de son changement de nom et de
l'arrêt total de l'activité jeux
d'échecs donc c'est dans les années 50
je suis tombé complètement par hasard
dessus en allant aux archives de la
ville de paris et en cherchant qu'est ce
qu'il y avait une date précise
où 161 de la rue saint-honoré donc
l'adresse actuelle du retrouver le café
la région âgés une que l'établissement
qui était là ne portait plus maintenant
donc voilà donc d'ailleurs à ce sujet si
vous allez au 151 rue saint-honoré dans
le centre de paris vous y trouverez
l'office du tourisme du maroc
on est bien loin de du jeu d'échecs et
comme beaucoup de gens il ya longtemps
j'avais fait la démarche de rentré au
café
à l'office de tourisme maroc et demander
à la personne qui était au guichet s'il
y avait quelque chose et j'ai bien
centré j'ai bien senti que je l'énervé
un petit peu que je vais pas être la
première personne à y poser la question
aucun enseignement à donner ça sert à
rien de rentrer poser la question c'est
un peu dommage c'est vrai d'avoir perdu
c'est alors encore dernière page un
convoi du blog avant de passer sur des
images du livre
et puis on va voir cette partie ensuite
pourquoi les particuliers dans le livre
la partie comme avant et dans livre
justement de quelques parties dans
l'immédiat pas que beaucoup de goût et
beaucoup de textes et beaucoup
d'anecdotes qu'il y avait là des images
et il ya aussi des quelques parties et
voilà bon bref alors donc ici on a une
anecdote intéressante ici c'est la table
des chefs du bonaparte voilà alors la
table des chèques de bonaparte c'est
toute une histoire
c'est une des reliques du café de la
régence qu'ils se trouvent où ici là on
y ont l'insigne cuisine ça on assez
difficile une nouvelle fois les
témoignages visuels de l'intérieur du
café de la région sont très limités donc
ça c'est une carte que j'ai trouvé aux
états unis une carte une photo quand
j'ai trouvé aux états unis et qui quand
j'ai vu ça je n'y croyais pas j'ai fait
du fichier tient un rôle en europe
l'agrandir je vais me mettre en avant
mais on voit ici à hop voilà regrettable
de bonaparte
voilà donc tape de bonaparte donc c'est
on est dans le nouveau café de la
régence et c'est une des tables de
l'ancien café de la régence nous d'avant
1854 sur laquelle il ya une plaque en
argent ou et indiqué que bonaparte
aurait joué là aux échecs car je crois
savoir et as tu vas pouvoir confirmer ou
infirmer
c'est que à l'époque il semblerait que
chacun avec un peu sa table il y avait
la table messieurs si oui monsieur
voltaire l'état de mon appart la table
de ceux ci la table cela et que au 18e
ou 19e alors c'est peut-être que ça pour
s'amuser je ne sais pas et qui servait
les clients en disant c'est sur la table
voilà ça ça parait il ya un texte qui
mentionne
servez à voltaire servait à olso et
c'est donc déjà il faut savoir que
voltaire était était un peu allergique
aux aux effets de mode et je suis pas
sûr qu'il ait mis les pièces les pieds
ou au café de la régence entendit grosso
par exemple était un fanatique du jeu
d'échecs 1 et avant même la table de
bonaparte j'ai un petit scoop un qui est
ce que c'est ça paraît dans un livre
d'un écrivain russe et s'appelle karam
usine qui a fait un tour de l'europe à
la fin du xviiie siècle et lui mentionne
une chaise sur laquelle aurait se serait
assis de nombreuses fois rousseau quand
il menait au café de la régence est le
propriétaire de l'époque l'exposait
comme comme une relique mèneront fait
voilà alors 7 c'est la seule fois où
j'ai trouvé mention de cette chaise de
rousseau et j'ai ce parce qu'elle est
venu ici c'était très bon il n'y a pas
de raison donc locaux 46 me manques sur
le suivi monte sur le sujet donc vers
1850 apparaissent est cette table de
bonaparte qui à mon avis et puis c'est
pas forcément la vérité dans ses tweets
au ça a été les gens voilà c'est une
légende mais la légende a fini par par
devenir auto réalisatrices coixet
les propriétaires qui sont suivis
montrer sa com comme une antiquité de
l'ancien café alors là qu'une photo
jolie simplement en anglais je traduis
en même temps thiès championnat date
play des joueurs des champions d'échecs
en train de jouer le senior capable en
cas d' oncle me capablanca le fameux
champion du monde
photographiée au fameux café de la
régence paris donc ça veut dire capable
en cas est passé au café l'argent oui
elle en ruine capablanca il vient je
crois que la première fois qui vient au
café de la régence à date du début du
20e siècle
il me semble qu'il vient de gagner deux
mémoires jeu il me semble qu'il vient de
gagner un tournoi en espagne il n'est
pas très connu et on y monte sur paris
pour aller dans ce lieu il viendra
nombre de nombreuses fois aux cassures
de la régence dans cette photo est un
peu plus tard 10
elle a été publiée dans le times je
crois en 1922 23 et donc elles
représentent en train de jouer contre un
très fort joueur parisien
arnold orback anale non encore annoncés
contre monsieur reback d'accord milieu
où la cape à longueuil et à droite non
non non et c'est lui qui a la main qui
s'apprête à s'éduquer à logis voilà ce
qu'il a l'air la gauche parle à l'air
plus âgées quand même un peu la photo
ait pas de très bonne qualité
voilà à quoi donc à palanquée à gauche
parce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la
khadra nous devons tous les joueurs
parisiens
étaient contents de recevoir les
champions qui venait de du monde entier
parce que déjà les voyages il se faisait
en bateau pour retourner dans le monde
aux états unis et la france est quand
même assez bien situé pour pour prendre
un bateau pour retourner aux états unis
donc les gens partaient en paquebot du
havre et faire un petit tour à paris au
café de la régence c'était c'était pas
mal à l'époque au début du 20e siècle il
y avait deux grands lieux emblématiques
pour le jeu d'échec avant il y avait le
café de la régence il y avait un autre
un autre lieu qui est ça a mis longtemps
à se stabiliser c'était un club d'échecs
proprement dit c'était le cercle
philidor et c'était les deux grands
il de grandlieu vous ne pouvez aux
échecs dans paris alors encore une photo
ici voilà on reconnaît un acteur très
connu exactement ça c'est une photo
vous pouvez voir son mari jean marais
qui qui est en train de manipuler des
pièces alors sur une table qui donc
serait une table wings et la table 2
ducasse et de l'argence alors par contre
je ne sais pas si ça a été si cette
photo a été prise au café de la régence
mais quelle table la table du café quand
tu dis la table de napoléon on voit sous
la table il ya une plaque alors je ne
sais pas non plus si c'est la plaque de
la photo précédente
on voit pas mais la définition est trop
mauvaise de la photo et j'ai jamais
réussi à voir qu'est devenue la table de
napoléon après les la fermeture du café
l'argent c'est un mystère
je doute qu'elles étaient détruites et à
mon avis elle doit être dans la
collection d'un particulier quelque part
en france sont en demande
ansa alors après on va passer à notre
parti wen peut-être y apprendre 3
quelques photos du livre quand on a une
partie très intéressante puisque si une
partie jouée face à aux fameux donc
figure bien entendu
voilà alors là ce qu'on peut précisé une
ces cafés gones à la régence donc alors
c'est une partie spéciale explique nous
pouvoir
oui alors ce qu'on a dit c'est que les
jeux de hasard était
et elles ont été combattus par par les
différents gouvernements
monsieur de sartine notamment au xviiie
siècle
mais les joueurs d'échecs il joue
ensemble on peut imaginer que leur
niveau sont différents donc les partis
se font un handicap et les anglais on
dit les handicaps qui sont assez variés
en ça peut être un pion et un trait ça
peut être un pion et de trail ça peut
être carrément un cavalier ça peut être
même une tour entière à ce sujet là il
ya quelque chose d'intéressant est ce
que un joueur qui rend une tour son
adversaire on appelle ça une mazette
voilà donc si vous pouvez jouer avec une
tour de moins quand votre adversaire
autres adversaires vous pouvez leur clé
une mazette c'est le terme officiel
terre officielle depuis le xviiie siècle
les voilà les termes exacts c'est le
terme exact c'est pas autre chose il
faut donner la tour voilà il faut donner
la toile et si vous pouvez donner la
dame à votre adversaire et le cran au
dessus en effet paru on appelle ça un
joueur de qui en fait un joueur de qui
conduisit avenue jean des logis le zèle
voilà dont le terme n'a disparu ce que
ce qu'on retient c'est le terme un peu
péjoratif de maaseik
on va s'amuser comme ça ça le ca le
terme de bien plus amusant voilà alors
là ils sont deux
donc il joue de bernard carlier joue
face à val d'or radio une joie d'une se
concertent
voilà alors c'est aussi au sujet de
chili dont on a très très peu
deux parties jouées par fils de rock
café de la régence et les partis qui
mentionne dans son manuel sont pour la
plupart soient départis de clients avant
ce vraiment ce soit des parties qu'il a
jouées en angleterre parce qu'il faut
savoir que fils d'or avait beaucoup
mécènes en angleterre donc il se rendait
régulièrement en angleterre pour
plusieurs mois pourrait in fine il abat
la même finale terry là bas il a intérêt
à londres voilà tout à fait donc là il
joue comme bernard garnier qui sont
ce ne sont pas n'importent qui ce sont
parmi les plus forts joueurs parisiens
de l'époque disons que c'est un cran en
dessous de philidor et donc philidor
peut se permettre en jouant contre eux
de rendre un pion quel est le pion du
trait alors le pion à 7 c'est le pion
traditionnelle en courant quand on vend
un pion et voilà donc tous via beaucoup
manuel d'échec d'ailleurs qui sont
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle où il
explique différents ouverture basé sur
les handicaps respectifs qu'on peut
donner à son adversaire
je suis obligé de faire un petite
parenthèse forcément dans le livre dont
ce fameux livre d'aurélie lopez la
dimension libérale du jeu d'échecs qui
en fait composé de quatre grandes
parties
il ya la quatrième partie ils traitent
justement de tous les deux tout les reds
justement de handicap
il va pas rendre le pion il va aussi
proposer les parties au rand cavaliers
celle mon père mais aussi d'intervertir
le roi et la tour contre
le trait enfin des choses très
compliquées en fait il ya une vingtaine
de cadenas fermé possible est différent
pour dire que ces vieux puits c'est ça
je pensais je voulais le signal est
quelque chose qui date d'au moins du 16e
siècle
si ce n'est plus anciens voilà les
joueurs jouent de l'argent sur la partie
donc ce handicap est censé équilibrer
les chances et philidor ne jouait que là
on tient compte de ses adversaires alors
une telle classe de différence que c'est
pas possible alors qu'andy goode ans et
de partir peut-être l'introduction il
faut la lire parce que c'est pas mal
voilà donc cette partie-là été publiés
dans le palamède en 1836 alors le pas la
même
en deux mots un c c'est la première
revue consacrée exclusivement au jeu
d'échecs qui est créée par la
bourdonnais en 1836 on ne veut pas rare
de l'introduction que le joueur le plus
extraordinaire qui est jamais paru
philidor donné le pion et très haut plus
fort joueur après lui il légal est
individuellement mais il perdait ou
faisait difficilement parties égales
lorsqu'ils voient eux mêmes avantages
contre deux d'entre eux réunis ayant le
conseil un contemporain de ce grand
maître nous a communiqué la partie
suivante doué en 1780 entre philidor
d'une part qu'à relier berne avant
d'autres d'une autre ban aux filles doré
noir d'allah à cannes il est blanc donc
c'est parti voilà donc que 4 4 au 6 mars
si c'était la réponse traditionnelle
quand on avait le handicap du pion en
moins on excepte la loi voilà déjà on
peut pas jouer au 5-1 puis à la dame qui
vient h
ah oui c'est vrai c'est moi suite d'un
bel 5 échecs et on le fameux si on joue
g6 d'empreintes pions échec et la
torride et donc la théorie de l'époque
disait que si c'était quasiment le seul
coup d'envoi handicap des cap des 5 10
tirs et théoricien handicap
on appelait face à la france l on
appelait ça la partie du roi du pion au
roi un pas d'accord donc plus on prend
des cinq qui comprend des sens et c'est
une partie qui a perdu fil du temps donc
je ne me semble pas qu'elle apparaisse
dans son
dans son manu non il est pas assez sûr
puis on prend des cinq rendez-vous alors
il a amélioré la marque l'échec mais ya
pas de parti radical dans ce manuel en
fait d'accord il ya que des partis est
il donne des conseils mais je n'en ai
même pas quoi penser que du tc de la
théorie ya pas d hier que des parties
généré rigoureusement théorique échec
voilà j'ai six langues la reine en plus
jouer j 6 dames 100 m et 5e j'ai quand
même mais et voilà donc ils forcent les
changes des dames et en cloud l'adav
fait qu'il ya pas la plus de la toile et
on veut échanger d'un avec les bleus en
fait non
alors l'une des particularités de
philidor qu'il aura du mal à mettre en
oeuvre dans cette partie c'est il aimait
beaucoup sacrifié une pièce compte
beaucoup de bien mais et après mené une
attaque avec sa dame et ses pions là
c'est pas trop le cadam va s'échanger
donc qui pourrait une fois il a joué
tout f4 il faut être quatre menace de
prendre et de pions raisonnement n'a
aucune sa c6 voilà on empêche la
présidence et 16 aux deux tranquille fou
g7 continue à se développer et à clamer
les changes l'examen du cavally voilà du
cavalier il faut pas faut pas perdre de
vue que les joueurs avec les blancs donc
sont en consultation les endroits de
parler mais étant litchi dorment et tout
seul avec son désavantage matériel ou
donc cavalier f 3,3 un petit rôle
fou et 5 comme vous le voyez la partie
et pas vraiment il n'ya pas vraiment de
ses pas vraiment romantique ya pas de
sacrifice de pièces dans tous les sens
et une partie assez moderne en amphi
viola et simplement arrêt jusqu'en
finale voilà le joueur il va échanger
toutes les pièces et bénéficier de son
tu en plus en cavalier 17 petit rock
prend pas là il prend le fou non voilà
qui a lié prend qu'à l'écran ouais il
faut prendre si on prend tous rescap
et oui il vient avec 4 pour empêcher que
les blancs jouent eux-mêmes f4 et il en
restera quatre attaques le mans et lyon
1 5
il a contré sans doute reporter au petit
puis aussi je vous jure c'est d'ailleurs
l'intérêt soit sm faut empêcher f1
il cherche l'activité à tout prix on
fout des trois fouet 5
donc s'ils n'arrivent pas à regagner le
pion aux 5
ce sera un peu dur mais s'il arrive
alors gagner nous il ya des ferries à
des chansons vous prend cavaliers
prendre prend mari prend
j'ai trois tours 4 elle attaque le pion
aux cinq lettres 4 des f4 donc en fait
c'est avec un échec
donc oui bénéficient d'un petit avantage
de développement mais on va voir ça pas
être suffisant donc tour aux deux tours
2 quand même la tour 7 team mais tord f2
sans doute voit pas sûr qu'il ya trois
cavaliers à 3 et vote
le cavalier protège le pion ces deux qui
va sans doute central rennais
les deux joueurs balancent développe
cavaliers aux trois cavaliers le tronc
attaque la tour et le pion ses deux
rêves de tout reprend voix prend enfin
les blancs sont contentes tout échange
les cavaliers j'ai quatre échecs qui ont
ragé deux tours des 8
voilà mais là ils ont vraiment joué
finement en fait ils sont pas rentrés
dans le jeu de philidor et ils ont un
avantage net est un pion à ses protégés
au centre l'ania un peu son banc pour
jour avec les morts nous le jour avec
les alentours des 1 tourner un cavalier
c'est tout dire l'idate rend alors à
temps mais pardon il ya jugé cap escudé
il ya eu autour des 8 h 3 j'ai sauté
n'est d'accord lorsque la willaya les
cas lieu 3 h 3 h trois mois je réagisse
up qu'elle est fils j'ai quatre autres à
l'arrêt 6 j'avais sauté guinée nous
voilà à mon tour d un même tour d un
vis-à-vis de retour cavalière 7h cat
il continue d'avancer
ces 5 ces trois des cinq ils avancent
majorité de pions ici cavaliers ces deux
mais il voit la saisie de ces blocs et
maintenant à celles qui ont accueilli au
3l temps des quatre des cats
donc je pourrai seul il est perdu ce
pion exactement je comprends qu'on prend
on comprend que la laisser deux vrais le
pion de mort des trois là on va en venir
en aide voilà qu'il y ait un des deux
cas les trois termes et philidor
abandonne voilà déjà père d'un deuxième
pion et ya rien à faire il n'y a rien à
faire
donc voilà bon parti donc cette
partie-là un intérêt surtout historique
voilà c'est probablement d'une des
seules choses qui est connue à ce jour
joué par fille dort au café de la région
voilà je suis bien de voir fils de
reperdre un peu parce que bon on le voit
gagner tout le temps ces grèves c'est
quand même un petit peu souhaite alors
on va me revoir aussi maintenant
peut-être en plus grand sur la vidéo on
va simplement essayer de d'avoir une
vidéo hui tout petit peu plus grande
pour montrer à la caméra avec thor des
passages de son livre alors de celui de
ce fameux livre mon café de la région ce
tome 1 ici alors vienne il ya déjà des
passages où il ya des photos seins il ya
quelques illustrations il ya quelques
parties mais mon idée c'était surtout de
ne pas faire un livre technique
alors ici qu'est ce que c'est que cette
illustration
alors ça c'est un tableau 2
louis léopold boilly c'est un peintre
français de la fin du 19e siècle et le
tableau est intitulé bain des joueurs
d'échecs au café la régence mais on n'a
pas plus aux renseignements sur sur ce
tableau
sauf que moi ce que je me suis dit c'est
que c'est pas un hasard si boilly seront
au café de la régence et qu' un des deux
joueurs est forcément fille de rang et
ensuite alors la photo epa en couleurs
néon voix sur le côté il ya un homme à
ces lieux là tu y es ici de ce côté là
avec un chapeau et puis tiens parapluie
sous le bras et il a un manteau alors là
elle est pas en couleur mais le manteau
il est vert et c'est pas anecdotique
parce que
en fait le gall avait donc le cir de le
gall le fameux qui était l'entraîneur
le premier intervient en dehors de fils
d'or et l'auteur du fameux matt de le
gall est l'auteur du fameux match de le
gall et ben il avait la réputation
d'avoir un manteau vert qui est qu'il
gardait systématiquement et une
casquette
donc c'est pour ça que bon j'extrapole
peut-être un petit peu mais il me semble
que c'est peut-être le gall qui est qui
est là est la personne à peu rabelais
avec le la main sur la joue je me dis
que c'est peut-être fils identiques qui
ont été représentés par par bouygues jeu
ça m'étonnerait quand même que ce soit
un hasard qui viennent l'avait qui
dessine quand quelqu'un comme ça mais
bon je pense que ça restera à l'état
alors une autre une autre illustration
que l'on trouvera dans ce livre aussi
alors qu'il advint joueurs apparemment
alors oui tout à fait alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'après philidor les
la france elle tient ce qu'on appelle le
sceptre des échecs de nombreuses années
et le successeur de philidor c'est un
certain des chapelles donc alexandre
lebreton des chapelles et
on peut moi je l'appelle en fait le
baron münchausen des échecs
c'est un personnage absolument
exceptionnel il a un parcours
c'est digne d'un roman en fait et
d'ailleurs il ya une personne en france
qui a consacré beaucoup d'études à son
sujet c'est monsieur baudriller qui a
écrit pas mal de textes à son sujet j'ai
trouvé quelques informations pour
compléter sa biographie et je consacre
un chapitre à deschapelles à un petit
chapitre donc été aussi un des les
sociétaires du café alors des chapelles
ses débuts du 19e siècle
ensuite car lui aussi alors ça c'est le
sacré d'un damien voilà alors donc c'est
sur lui c'est la bourdonnais dans le je
crois le père c'est le père qui a
découvert la réunion c'est ça qui s'est
installée la réunion non en fait on
s'est associés passé il ya quelque chose
avec lui explique alors en fait il se
fait appeler le petit-fils de la
bourdonnais alors la bourdonnais était
un un explorateur mandaté par le roi
pour pour explorer l'océan indien
c'est le premier gouverneur de l'île
de la réunion son ancêtre mais en fait
je montre que c'est pas son petit fils
mais qu'il s'agit de son arrière grand
père
et pourquoi la bourdonnais se fait
appeler petit-fils de ces navigateurs
parce que à la fin de sa vie la
bourdonnais a des gros problèmes
financiers et il apprend qu'il est
possible d'obtenir une aide d
d'une association d'écrivains de france
et lui il a publié un livre en dans les
années 1820 qui était signée par le
petit-fils de la bourdonnais lui et il
prétend que c'est lui qui a écrit ce
livre pour avoir un argument
supplémentaire pour toucher une pension
de cette association ou d'ailleurs mais
en fait la personne qui a écrit le livre
c'est réellement le petit-fils du
navigateur le labourdonnais mais c'était
un oncle de la bourdonnais joueur
d'échecs qui portait le même prénom est
le même que lui voilà donc il a un peu
usurpé la mettais à la preuve de ce
budget la preuve de ça ça c'est un rang
ces informations que vous donner c'est
inédit dans la biographie de qui est
d'en attendre un second tome 1 mais j'ai
trouvé ça aux archives de paris
je suis tombé sur des actes notariés de
la famille labour de noël qui démontre
voilà j'ai également trouvé là que je
pense être la vraie date de naissance de
la bourdonnais puisqu'il a il a aussi
entretenu un certain mystère là dessus
sur la pseudo fortune de sa famille
aussi j'ai trouvé des renseignements à
ce sujet là encore alors ici alors ça ça
c'est intéressant
ces illustrations à notre avenir voilà
c'est une des très rares représentations
de l'ancien café de la régence donc
l'ancien café l'argent s'il j'ai géré
mon temps pour aller m'en faisais
l'ongle
de la rue saint-honoré et de la place du
palais royal
donc cette gravure date de 1850 ou 52 et
d'un certain texier elle apparaît dans
un recueil de gravure sur paris enfin on
va pour finir on va voir encore je crois
qu'il ya oui je suis là et c'est enfin
en avoir un très grand joueur aussi
assez connu de succès intéressé à
l'histoire du jeu sont des joueurs que
juste avant de parler de ses
connaissances de saint-amand voilà ce
qui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que des
chapelles dont on dans la plupart des
joueurs d'échecs ont brièvement et avait
la réputation d'être plus fort que
philidor et la bourdonnais son suivant
avait également la réputation d'être des
trous moins aussi fort que que des
chapelles et à la mort prématurée de la
bourdonnais le plus fort joueur qui se
dégage c'est probablement saint-amand
dont vous voyez la gravure qui est ici
et saint-amand il va avoir eu il va
avoir le malheur de perdre son match en
1843 contrôle staunton alors ce match
toute une histoire parce que saint-amand
est un négociant en vins et l'a
d'ailleurs écrit un livre sur les vins
de bordeaux dont qui est excellent d'air
il avait il avait une boutique de vente
en gros de vin qui situé à une vingtaine
de mètre vingt trente mètres du café de
la régence donc il y avait l'occasion de
s'y rendre régulièrement et saint-amand
donc aller de temps en temps
en angleterre pour faire commerce de son
vin et il en profitait à londres may
pour jouer aux échecs et ans au début de
l'année une forme cod planer 1843 il
fait un petit match contre staunton
match qui l'emportent et les deux
joueurs qu'on viennent de faire un match
revanche
à l'automne à paris et saint-amand va
perdre le match et va perdre le match et
du coup c'est la fin de la suprématie
des échecs français dans le monde et il
faudra attendre ben ali qui n'attendent
avoir un nouveau champion du monde
ça viendra bien plus tard donc mais bien
plus tard on a acheté une illustration
très intéressante parce que ça c'est la
rendre compte du jeu d'échecs et de la
grande histoire tu vas parler tout à le
voilà de ce fameux match extraordinaire
ont connu jusqu'à présent fait une
révélation du donald est presque on dit
qu'on fait entre morphine napoléon iii
et là on a aussi alors qu'est ce que
c'est cette grave voilà un sas et une
gravure qui représente les combats sur
la place du palais royal en février 1848
ouais donc au fond il ya un bâtiment où
on voit justement on le devine il ya un
bâtiment où il ya des coups de feu qui
semble partir et il ya une barricade sur
le pont de la ici de l'autre côté temps
ici on est écrit en petit café de la
région c'est l'angle de la rue où il ya
le café l'argent seuil à la population
parisienne
kitty en fait sur les
sur l'armée qui est qu'ils se trouvent
réfugié au château d'eau donc c'est un
bâtiment qui n'existe plus le château
d'eau et moi je fais un parallèle un
petit peu entre le château d'eau et la
bastille en 1789 les parisiens ont pris
la bastille ont démoli le bâtiment
ben la révolution de 1848 qui sape qui
chasse louis philippe
ben el assa bastille avec le château
d'eau en fait et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que donc saint-amand faisait
partie des gardes nationaux à l'époque
de la révolution de 1848 et il a sauvé
en quelques temps après le palais des
tuileries de la destruction et du
pillage total guy philippe adam que je
regarde c'est un saint-amand a eu un
rôle il donc en sauvant ce palais des
tuileries donc la garde nationale en
quelques mots c'était un peu une milice
bourgeoise qui est qui était chargée du
maintien de l'ordre d'un pari mais elle
elle se garde bien de prendre part à la
révolution de 1848 les troupes de lignes
c e qui défendent le palais royal et le
château d'eau c'est elle qui se font
tirer dessus par la population et la
gare nationale constituée des bourgeois
reste un peu en l'écart mais lui
officiers de la garde nationale est
chargé par le gouvernement provisoire
avec notamment lamartine d'aller en
pêcher le pillage du palais des
tuileries
voilà donc ça c'était le tome 1 du café
de la région dans cette émission
spéciale des gonades des verts pour
terminer cette émission là on a on a
vraiment bien combler notre heure de
conte a même dépassé je crois que je
pourrais en parler pendant des heures en
gestion alors bien sûr alors mais
évidemment le lecteur maintenant si vous
en voulez en savoir plus il faut vous
procurer ce tome qui est vraiment extra
et le prochain à venir donc tome 2 600
pages de cafés de la région de 1680 à
1850 2,55 et ensuite le tome 2 ans a
fait la suite
alors ça s'appelle donc le café de la
régence voilà tohme un parent donc laure
olivier lecomte en quelques mots donc
il en vend pour l'instant uniquement sur
un seul site un le site de l'invs sur
ton blog sur la zone rouleau trouverez
le lien est évident en ghsr
prochainement le mettre en vente sur
amazon mais là ça sera sur le ce sera
sur le site de la du championnat de
france toutes façons d'y glisser dans
l'émission voilà donc le café la région
du jeu d'échecs 200 ans d'histoire au
palais royal comme le pain j'ai enlevé
le compte voilà avec une j'aime beaucoup
la phrase d'entrée la ici si vous voulez
vivre en paix avec votre coeur est avec
votre esprit ne mettait pas le pied dans
le café de la régence
voilà je vous rappelle j'en profite donc
pour vous rappeler parce que c'est lié à
la sortie donc de l'an dernier donc
toujours disponible bien obtenu chez les
libraires fille dort analyse du jeu
d'échecs entièrement remasterisés et
moderne avec un échiquier tous les 4 ou
donc là c'est une issue plutôt un livre
pour les débutants et qui veulent
apprendre avec un grand champion de
l'histoire et à sortir donc apparaître
dans cette émission
l'annoncé pour la première fois
apparaître aussi en octobre donc la
reddition du fameux manuel de ruines au
ps de ciboure a que faire environ 450
pages voilà
là aussi on traiter d'intérêt historique
mais aussi technique avec mme danielle
trois quart de livre ses fans des partis
mais avec des règles du jeu d'échecs un
tout petit peu différente et ça ça
serait expliqué plus tard voilà donc le
café lagence trône merci beaucoup jean
olivier adam et moi même participé à
cette émission littérature histoire
cafés de la région ce grand champion
moi j'adore sa voix la passion du jeu
d'échecs y compris dans le temps et pas
uniquement sur les souches ou quatre
cases je vous donne rendez vous bientôt
pour une émission des gonades tv sur le
souhait que la france bien entendu au
revoir et enfin à une prochaine fois